[Music]
a moped stops in front of a convenience
store
a robber wearing a helmet and a face
mask enters and threatens the cashier
with a gun to extort a watch or money
many young criminals think it is simple
and easy
but then a plainclothes policeman or a
carabanyera
witnesses the robbery and it ends with
deadly consequences
fifteen-year-old hugo rosso died when a
military policeman opened fire on him in
the middle of the night
in the elegant heart of naples
my son was murdered he was shot twice in
the chest
and once in the back of his head
hugo russo's father and his youngest son
stand in front of a huge mural that
dominates a small square in the spanish
quarter
it is an image of hugo staring at his
family and neighbors
demanding truth and justice
the fact that hugo committed an armed
robbery is not spoken of here
many approve of his mural and complain
about police violence and slow
investigations
they claim that the legal proceedings
against the military policemen never
really started
therefore the russo family is receiving
more and more support
also from those who demand clarification
as well as more
solidarity between the rich and the poor
in naples
the prevailing mentality in this city is
to each his due
there's no social solidarity the rich
remain rich
the poor remain poor a youth who commits
a crime should be
shot it's his own fault
hugo's father who has been known to the
police since adolescence
also believes this to be true
nobody in this city genuinely wants to
know why such robberies occur
why these young people do such things
they just want to destroy us
to trample us like vermin
we visit another neighborhood with
another mural this one commemorates
seventeen-year-old luigi kayafa
with candles in an altar last october he
too was shot dead by a policeman in
civilian clothes
whilst committing a robbery
meanwhile the mural has been removed by
the police
criminals should not be glorified the
reaction in the neighborhood is
aggressive
people are angry at the state young
criminals portrayed as saints
religious worship within the kimura
naples mafia
is well known to priest luigi marola he
has been fighting against it for 20
years
as if the bad
the priest works against these illegal
demonstrations of power and has also
been threatened
however behind high walls he continues
to do youth work
now during the pandemic he helps youths
with homework online
and in normal times with recreational
activities
families hit particularly hard by the
pandemic receive aid to stop the next
generation from getting
further involved in criminal activity
every neighborhood has its clan boss but
most of these bosses are now in prison
many young people take advantage of this
they form gangs that fight each other
this increases violence because the
actual boss has lost
control and can no longer maintain order
in the neighborhood like before
[Music]
in addition the characters of popular
mafia series become real role models for
many young people
experts say this increases rivalry and
the readiness for violence in the
streets
[Music]
violence is justified so to speak as the
state doesn't intervene
there is a lack of perspective from
police or prosecutors
which makes the criminals feel they can
get away with anything
without being arrested prosecuted or
held responsible
[Music]
but perhaps times are changing because
more and more people in naples are
calling for the image of hugo russo to
be removed
a 15 year old small time crook is no
saint
no god like the god of soccer a few
streets away
only diego armando maradona the deceased
idol who once played for ssc naples
unites the city and may be worshipped
like a saint
by good and evil alike